[Music]
welcome back to careful boys where these
boys have been careful their entire
lives since birth
really really great yeah they're still
boys though for sure yeah still boys you
think that that that word like boys will
be boys you know how like now they're
saying like oh it it excuses boys from
being like [__] up but like there is i
don't think it excuses them but it
explains why they do dumb [__] but i
don't think it's excuse for certain
things for certain i actually question
if boys don't do extreme [__] when
they're young like did you have a
childhood because i think every boy that
i was around did some stupid [__]
[__] in my mind boy boys will be boys is
not like perversion or sexual [__] it's
it's just guys will challenge rules and
they would do things risky and
adventurous that they're not supposed to
do that might be dangerous like
physically yeah or sometimes
harmful to animals or harmful to [__]
property you know yeah property damage
yeah what are some things you guys
[__] up as kids oh dude
my friend derek would um it was raining
one day and he
we found that pulling weeds was really
easy when it was raining and so he
started pulling all these weeds up and
so you think that's going to be we're
doing good thing right no no no derek
had a different idea
[Laughter]
he takes the weeds with all the dirt
clumped on the bottom of it and he just
starts beating it against people's
porches
so we're like
he's like [__] up all the porches and
he's laughing and i'm laughing i'm not
doing it but i'm laughing and that's
when i learned about guilt by
association
oh yeah and my mom found out about it
and then i had to go clean all the
porches up with him and then
yeah because you were complicit because
i was complicit you know i didn't do it
hey in a similar situation you know you
know those uh [__] i don't know i
don't know what plants are called the
ones that
have [__] cypress plants around and
[__] those little community centers
right they got those birds of paradise
uh no no the purpley ones though they uh
anyways oh the ones it's like it's like
green but there's purple there's like
flowers yes yes those things
they hurt like crazy but the thing is
they're all so fun too i was you know
doing taekwondo so they were fun to like
chop and feel like you could break
something yeah yeah and i remember the
first time that i discovered the ability
to like chop one and just like see it
snap and being like yo
i'm [__] powerful right yeah i'm a
master
maybe 45 minutes later every single hour
in the entire community
i swear to god probably seven
seven you can't be stopped dude seventh
and eighth grade i probably took out all
those flowers on artesia that's what i'm
saying
the [__] city of our teacher he's
like what's happening to our [__]
[Laughter]
there are council meetings being had
over your [__] yeah
we gotta go find them you know
you know exactly what's up we gotta go i
wanna try this out like badass yeah and
then i and then when my mom found out
she told my dad i got beat she finally
because every single one outside of the
dry cleaners is free dumbass doing
[__] karate i'm just doing karate
he's like kayak
what do you do the next day when there's
no one left i i just i was already beat
so like i wasn't allowed to do it ever
again yeah yeah because one of the type
of plants that the city planted yeah the
city plant city so yeah i'm not messing
with my mom's plants you know what i
mean i just
i thought they were public plants
you feel like uh like an anime character
because you hit it right that the
[__] top of the flower bud flies off
and the bottom part kind of goes like
this yeah
it's like boom
it's like like pass right
or she got revenge through your dad dude
it's like you bike by and kick him
the fact that you would bicycle buy and
kick well you just start taking it up a
notch more and more and more and
skipping so mobile with your service get
better and better
he's leveling up every time
i apologize to the city of cyprus
that's good i'm sure somebody took it up
after you stopped yeah [__] that's a
that's an instinct thing obviously if
two out of six people
grew up hitting those that's how you
claim your territory you know i knew he
was artesia you know what i mean i
stayed on this side
so funny though just imagine little kids
just [__] jumping you're driving by
like [__] little [__] yeah i
don't see [__] like that anymore i feel
like that was like you don't see kids
play in the streets i don't even see
kids outside i saw i saw a couple kids
playing on their neighborhood for the
first time in like 10 years dude they
got like sickest video games and phones
now we didn't have that so you just
[__] chop it up flowers now that i
have a neighborhood though
i swear to god if i don't have
trick-or-treaters i'm gonna be [__]
pissed i'll take a bullhorn through my
neighborhood and be like where the [__]
are the trick-or-treaters
i've been waiting my whole life for this
[__] you like you like uh when kids come
in like yeah but i've never had it
before because i lived in la and i
always lived like in whatever unit you
know has a gate around it [__] giving
out candy is pretty fun i remember we
were um me and my buddy were shooting bb
guns because he had all these like cool
pellet rifles right and then we would
like to put up bottles his dad would
save his like beer and [__] so we could
shoot him and the glass could like
explode and we're like cool we were all
latchkey kids no one was home and this
was like sixth grade and [__] we were
like shooting
right and then he's like hey have you
ever been hunting i'm like oh i've never
been hunting and we're like let's start
shooting some birds so we were like
shooting the crows [__] sparrows
missing most of them right but the cool
thing was it was a huge tree
when you [__] shoot and it goes boom
right it hits the leaves and all of
these birds fly out of the tree so we
started shooting the [__] trees
and then we saw this one crow
on top of this uh air conditioning we
shot a guy
and we're just like we're gonna get that
[__] crow we're gonna get that big
[__] crow right so we load it up and
we just started spraying it
and then we started hitting the [__]
air ac unit right
because then it was like the bird left
but we like we just like shooting the
[__] yeah you hear the noise
yeah cause you're like oh you're hitting
something the [__] out of there the the
neighbor's ac unit
it hits the fad and then we hear it
going
[Laughter]
and then we're like holy [__] vandalism
dude
all these stories are bad vandalism this
is all so he [__] ran in the [__]
house and threw the [__] guns and we
got on our bicycles and we left dude
just looking left the
scene of the crime man
like the [__] ac's in the fridge the
av was riddled with bullets dude
that's definitely a notch up because
that's private property oh dude oh dude
what smart thing did anybody do with the
pellet gun nothing nothing nothing
without adult supervision and [__]
what you can't give sixth grade either
sixth graders a [__] air gun like
yeah you really think that the one piece
of paper colored target that you can
post up somewhere it's like that's all
the fun that there is to have like yeah
right dude we were such [__] bags that's
like the training paper only you know
dude in back then it's not the plastic
ones i'm talking about it's the [__]
copper ones yeah dude the copper ones
yeah it's the pellet ones that look like
salt stickers the lead yeah it's like a
little chess piece yeah yeah because i
remember when we were biking around the
older bullies they would literally
[__] shoot at us with those yeah holy
[__] we would hit our leg and [__] we
would bleed yeah kill rodents with those
things yeah yeah when we were when we
were riding by we'll be like don't go
around that guy's house because if you
if you don't bike fast enough he's going
to [__] pop you
yeah
do you do you remember um in cerritos
town center there's like a fountain yeah
have you ever seen that covered in
[__] foam yes
i used to put [__] bubble bath in
that [__]
oh yeah
do you put it you know around cerritos
there's rocks and rivers too you ever
put it in those two no i only would put
it in that one fountain i would take the
the cow you know like the [__] public
transit uh to go you went all the way
there just to do that and then we would
just put [__] have the whole thing a
bubble bath in there i kind of want to
try this entire street would just be
[__] covered in bubbles and then you
just sit back yeah
and you just go
burn
how old are you
i was like [__] middle school for
sure yeah i was like fifth grade this is
a random [__] but you know uci there's
there's also like fountains and stuff in
different places right uh we used to
have this foam party
all right so i remember going to phone
phone party's a [__] disgusting thing
yeah it's not it's not what you have a
hell of fun right anyways so uh you get
drunk and stuff and everything like that
i remember i was partying there with
like mike and a bunch of other like
college friends right and michael ended
up
sorry mike um
he ends up like you know seeing some
chick or whatever they saw like hanging
out you know i'm like drunk as [__] me
and some of the boys start leaving right
and then one of the fountains well i
like i'm like [__] it dude let me go in
here and clean off a little bit and jump
in one of the fountains and then i'm
taking a piss and i'm like yeah you know
it's like recycling water
and then like we go back to the to the
apartment and then like maybe like an
hour later mike shows back up right but
we knew he was with his chicks so we're
all like oh what happened you know he's
like no nothing to do it's just kind of
like fun a little romantic what'd you
guys do it's like oh you know actually
after right after we left
uh we just saw like this fountain in the
in the middle of whatever so like we it
was kind of cool and cute we like jumped
in we're just like splashing around
i'm like is it the fountain in social
sciences he's like yeah all right
um my bad dude i peed in there right
before you showed up oh god
you're having a romantic
like oh they're bathing in your [__]
urine
oh splashing each other
that it was pee-pee night in the
fountain they're pretty freaking slim
why did you feel obligated to tell him
at that point i'm just like i'm not
saying
i was still drunk today's video is
brought to you by dipsy if you're
thinking about making like a resolution
this year okay the year is still new yep
instead of like depriving yourself you
know like i'm gonna quit this i'm gonna
do that why not focus on providing for
yourself with dipsy you can focus on
providing yourself just a little bit of
pleasure in life yeah so what dipsy is
it's short sexy audio stories so maybe
you're like you know what i need to take
take a little break from porn but you're
like but how can i still be romanticized
by myself and giving myself a little
pleasure have you ever tried it through
the ears
because i like romance novels and me i'm
a i'm a lover of hentai comics but you
know at night if i'm just looking at
stuff i can't go to sleep because i'm so
turned on and i'm just like man
also the blue light even though i if i
use the blue light blockers if i'm
looking on my phone like it just keeps
me awake you masturbate with blue light
blockers on yeah i mean it just makes
everything a little bit less yellow but
like still i don't know that's why i
like to close my eyes and go into a
world where only good things happen life
is already freaking hectic and we don't
need no more hecticness especially when
you're scrolling through what is the
best porn out there so let's just get
into a world where only good things
happen and we can explore and pleasure
our fun imaginations and we can relax
like that so dipsy stories is an app
full of sexy audio stories
and now they even have brand new written
stories too
and they have hundreds of stories to
choose from and they release one every
week so there's always more to explore
baby and they also have wellness
sessions to help you wind down and relax
you know sometimes you just need to put
on an app and go to sleep because man
i'm telling you youtube be too
stimulating sometimes
yeah so if this sounds interesting to
you go to dipsy.com off the record to
get a extended 30-day free trial keyword
free try it out
dipsy.com off the record that's
d-i-p-s-e-a.com
off the record one of my uh most
unintentional
forms of or crazy yeah crazy forms of
vandalism was when i was uh no we're
just calling it that yeah
boys will be curious is what it is i
think i was like maybe seven
and my mom would come out to monterey
park because it's like asian central so
she would come out here to get like
acupuncture or chiropractor stuff done
and then so she would go in her room and
then she'd be gone for like 30 minutes
45 minutes when they put the needles in
or whatever right and i'm just a kid in
the waiting room and then my mom comes
every week so in the beginning i'm just
reading the magazines and you kind of
get bored so i'd go in the extra room
where they have the table where they put
like the wax paper over the the pillow
and then um you know how they had like
those glass the glass cupping things
yeah and then there would be like a
lighter
so i take the lighter and i would like
burn the wax paper and it looks dope
because it goes
like that right so it's it i'll go like
that and i just keep burning it and then
blowing it out and each time i would
prolong the the blowout to see like
how like you're pushing it now it's
trying to push it
so now it goes to the pillow
and when it got to the pillow i was like
oh [__] and i i couldn't put it out so
i'm like oh [__] so i run into the
waiting room and then i'm like
pretending like everything's all chill
because i don't want to get in trouble
you know the water dispenser the cups
are [__] this yeah they're super
small
i [__] walk all gentle and i [__]
spread to the room like go like this and
it starts and it keeps burning
and i did that maybe like three or four
times my mom was done she was like
signing the cone cup yeah my mom
i keep pulling my mom's pants and my mom
we gotta go we gotta we gotta go we
gotta go she's like why i'm like just we
gotta go
and then one of the [__] nurses runs
out she goes the bed is on fire what's
going on
[Laughter]
i was so [__] scared that i was like
seven years old oh [__]
when we were driving away i could see
smoke coming out of the windows in the
front door like through the rear seat
nurses choosing to commit suicide rather
than have to go into the burning blaze
these lanes are running out on fire oh
my god man you see the doctor crawling
out of the window and [__] and that was
the last day of that establishment did
your mom know
that place doesn't exist but it used to
be of course it does it you burned it
for cinder but it's a historical site
now you set it on fire but you know like
garfield avenue where abc cafe is it was
like one or two units down from there
did your mom know you burned it i think
she did but i forgot i gotta ask you
guys
and now it's a memorial
for these three nurses that died and
they're melting in the flames
you're such a funny bad kid bro i can't
believe that because like any one of us
kids would have seen that whole
structure and not had the balls to do it
but like
damn you had like you were missing that
inhibition that sounds like so like
[__] barf
that's that's bart dude arson barton
bart had a plan but then he didn't have
a resolution
the cuffs were too small he couldn't do
[__] about it except for the legs i was
just curious like when um that's an
icarus moment because you just got too
close to the [__] pillow why did you
just get the belt [__]
i don't know no you panicked with fire
and [__] you panicked how to put fires
out when the fire is actually burning
because he knew he wasn't supposed to be
doing that i know this story but it
literally comes out in a second it's
like and it's full that's how small the
[__] cup is and i don't want to give
it away so i'm like like watching how
peaceful
it's just a little ass like splash
damn bro
so yeah
as a disclaimer boys will be boys is
never a [__] phrase i've ever heard
that excuses me from punishment they say
it while they beat your ass
we got our asses beat for every [__]
bad thing we did [__] dude i deserve
most of my meetings
i swear to god we just said everything
dudes are just curious like i used to go
to my mom to get acupuncture too and
then you know when you get like it all
over your back i don't know if you guys
got it before sometimes they'll put like
those electro things looking like
twitches
and i'm like laying there and my [__] is
kind of boring
and i'm like i'm like i wonder if i
could like get off the table
get off the table
oh [__] don't get back on oh my [__] i
got to listen to this [__] dental
office music then
you're just bored just want to try new
[__]
[Laughter]
those electro nodes i can't believe how
much damage you did as a single digit
age kid
that's my job i remember like um
my dad in the in the garage would have
uh these upright pianos
and then so there was uh you know he
teaches piano and all that but he also
fixes them and then he would get like
some you know old ones and then he would
like make him new and [__] and then um i
got into my brother's like he had a huge
like toolbox right
and he taught me how to use pliers the
other day wire cutters so i went inside
and i just wanted some [__] to like cut
and then
i had a there was an open piano
with all of the [__]
i just went in and i just went
episode this [__]
5 000 piano just ruined it the whole
time
you hear my dad teaching piano he's
doing a piano lesson so there's music in
the background and i'm like
[Laughter]
it just had [__] wires popped out
i got my ass [__] beat like crazy
good
good advocates yeah i am actually child
violence i got [__] up dude i'm
starting to think maybe joe needs to
apologize to his father
that's a big [__] absolutely bro dude
your dad's an [__] we started hearing
these stories like wait no wonder he
left right
now you're just a kid though how did he
find it he tried
later on i'm just like back in the house
[__] playing with a truck or
something i just feel like wow what the
[__] you know
did you try to explain yourself i don't
even
know i don't know what happened yeah
yeah i would do it something
yeah what else we can do with these
things i mean that must have felt really
satisfying to cut people oh hell yeah i
bet that the weird thing is it's worth
it right so like a menace like me you
would think that my parents wouldn't let
me touch kitchen things cook
tools
all those things
they just taught me how to use the tools
and i can do it whenever i wanted to
so that's the solution yeah so they gave
you all the power and none of them none
of the responsibility i started cooking
hella early i remember like i was like
oh man i'm gonna make my parents some
sandwiches and [__] you know and i
wanted to use the [__] uh what do you
call it the baloney the turkey baloney i
like it fried so i put like oil in there
[__] made some sandwiches and then
later i brought it out and then they're
like what the [__] and i'm like what
and then there was just grease all over
the floor
and i was like i was trying to make
sandwiches for you
fried turkeys it's their fault
there's oil on the floor but there's
hello
you can [__] you can [__] roller
skate
yeah you can [__] have a hockey game
on it dude trying to do something good
though at least i know the piano strings
thing there was no upside to that that's
hey your piano is broken
these wire cutters good thing you fix
these make a sign says needs fixing
[Music]
[Applause]
you